décadas de latente extensiones y
divisiones étnicas que se hallaron con
violencia durante esta semana en el
estado de manipur al noreste de India
dejando docenas de muertos y miles de
desplazados así como el corte de
internet la militarización de la región
por parte de las autoridades indias
los militares Cuqui atacaron tras rodear
nuestra aldea emputado empezaron a
dispararnos con sus armas presas del
pánico abandonamos nuestras pertenencias
y huimos para salvar nuestras vidas
el martes miles de personas participaron
en una manifestación estudiantil en
rechazo a la posible inclusión como
tribu especial registrada destinada a
las minorías del país al grupo
mayoritario hindú los maytei lo que
desató una oleada de ataques es
terremoto estado es un mosaico de grupos
con diferencias culturales y religiosas
a menudo enfrentados entre sí los nagas
y cookies son tribus cristianas de las
montañas y rechazan la inclusión de los
mayté y en esta categoría alegando a que
está destinada a los grupos
socioeconómicamente más desfavorecidos
los malhechores atacaron de repente
incendiaron un pueblo vecino obligándome
a huir Aunque al principio dudé mis
hijos me convencieron para que escapara
se quedaron en el pueblo y me preocupa a
su seguridad
el polémico estatus le otorga beneficios
como empleos públicos o acceso a
universidades y recursos adicionales por
lo que las tribus minoritarias en Ven
ahora perder estas ventajas